this is not a phone it's a super camera
phone on the face of it Huawei is one of
the great success stories of the 21st
century
but since Donald Trump outlawed us
companies from doing business with the
Chinese firm last week Google has now
said it won't allow Huawei to use it
Android mobile operating system which
could hit its phone sales hard what you
won't have access to is the apps Play
Store from Google which is basically all
those different millions of apps that
people will understand their friends
have got you have to use the app gallery
from Huawei if it continues in the same
way and that means you haven't got
access to the top app so we're thinking
all the social medias Facebook and
Instagram etc video-on-demand
all these won't be there and why it's
gonna have to get app developers to come
and do that and there's no sign they
will at this point Huawei doesn't really
need to sell handsets in America with
barely any exposure to the US market the
company sold more than 59 million phones
worldwide in the first quarter of this
year chasing Samsung's 72 million in top
spot with Apple down in third place at
just 36 million for now this is all
about huawei's mobile phones and whether
or not in future they'll be able to use
google apps but it's not really about
that at all handsets and YouTube videos
are a byproduct the real story is about
Wi-Fi and the next generation 5g there
you are way is way ahead of the field
but Donald Trump and many others in the
West believe that if they allow our way
into their networks it'll be a Trojan
horse allowing the Chinese state to spy
on us
Wow he feels it's collateral damage in
the trade war between two economic
heavyweights we feel like a football in
the middle of two giants this is a trade
war issue where the United States and
China right in the middle of a trade war
the timing of the executive order which
came out last week is cynical and is
clearly aimed at maximizing the damage
to war away at a critical point in the
Train ago she ations
there appears to be little faraway can
do to fight back international lawyers
say Google had no option but to pull it
software the penalties for violating
that regulation which says that no
software or technology or
US origin Goods can go to hallway the
penalties go well depending on how much
you export could be in the millions and
and really the the biggest possible
penalty is that you lose your privilege
to export from the United States which
no US business that does any
international work could live with in
short if you have a far way phone
already the Android operating system
will be supported but any new version
won't be given to why away their
opponents kindness